- [Narrator] If you've been
waiting on a package for weeks,
your order might be here,
stuck at sea in a shipping container.
The COVID pandemic has
snarled global supply chains
causing massive backlogs and shortages
that have some companies
stockpiling goods in trailers
and chartering private container ships.
But these are temporary fixes.
For longer-term solutions,
some companies are looking
to make sweeping changes
to their supply chains,
including shifting
manufacturing closer to home,
but pulling off these strategies
can require retooling a complex
web of global production,
potentially adding new risks and costs.
First, here's how
a globally distributed
supply chain typically works.
In this case, for
Timberland's Pit Boss boots,
a shoe the company sells to
consumers in the US and beyond.
Sourcemap, a website that
publishes data about supply chains
says the materials,
including the leather and metal details
are sourced from locations
around the world,
including the US, the UK, China, Japan,
South Korea, Taiwan, and Vietnam.
All of these materials
are shipped to a factory in Bangladesh
where the boots are assembled.
The boots are transported
to a distribution center in Virginia,
where they're then shipped
off to retail locations
and customers around the world.
- Modern supply chains are
complex and they're far flung.
- [Narrator] Jen Smith
has been covering the forces
behind the supply chain issues
for the "Wall Street Journal."
She says that over the past few decades,
supply chains have become
increasingly global.
- With every step along the way,
there is the potential for disruption,
whether it's in manufacturing
or in transport,
or if you're having
trouble distributing it
once it gets here.
- [Narrator] Lately, disruptions
have caused extensive delays,
which has driven up
the cost of many goods.
So some companies
are looking at different
location strategies
to protect their supply chain
and their bottom line.
One idea being discussed
in corporate boardrooms
is called regionalization.
This involves setting up factories
in multiple parts of the world
so that operations in each region
are able to supply products
to the closest markets.
The idea is to minimize risk.
- Supply chain problems
happen all the time.
The most common pre-pandemic
was something to do
with a natural disaster
or a hurricane or a typhoon
or something affects the ability
to get stuff on the shelves
of your local grocery stores
so things are emptied out
and then that has a ripple effect
on the cost of transporting goods.
- [Narrator] So if a
company is regionalized,
a closed factory in one place
only impacts sales in nearby locations.
Companies are also looking at
shortening their supply chains
through a similar strategy
called nearshoring.
The concept is pretty simple.
It refers to the practice
of pulling production
that had been moved far away,
back to a country closer
to where the products
are distributed and sold.
And this strategy is
becoming more popular.
After facing shortages,
the Italian clothing company, Benetton,
decided to increase manufacturing
in Serbia, Croatia,
Turkey, Tunisia, and Egypt,
closer to where the
products are sold in Europe.
It's a big move.
The company plans to cut
its Asia production by half
over the next year or so.
It's a reversal of the decades long shift
by many apparel companies
to Asian factories that
offered low cost supplies.
Some companies are also using
a strategy called reshoring.
It's similar to nearshoring,
but in this case,
a company that previously
moved manufacturing overseas
moves it back to the country
where it was originally located.
- With reshoring, a
business may choose to move
some of its manufacturing
that it had been doing
elsewhere back to the US
if it had experienced trouble
getting the products here,
whether there wasn't enough
production capacity abroad,
or whether there were
transportation bottlenecks
that were preventing products
from getting here when they were needed.
- [Narrator] While moving production
could solve some supply chain issues,
these solutions aren't a fix-all
and they still carry risks.
Mainly, they're expensive to pull off.
According to a 2020 report,
the total combined cost for
US and European companies
to move manufacturing out of China
would come to some $1 trillion
over the next five years.
And for many smaller companies,
the costs are too high to bear.
- Some companies may not have enough money
to set up manufacturing domestically.
And even if they did,
it might not make sense
because their product might
end up costing twice as much
as it does.
So they are gonna have to
weigh the cost of delays
of a product that's made
elsewhere getting here.
What does that mean for their bottom line
versus would they have as
many buyers for that product
if they were making it domestically
and it costs twice as much?
- [Narrator] Overhauling
entire supply chains
can also take years.
(horn honking)
Still, some companies
think these strategies
could pay dividends for the future
and help their businesses survive.
(bright lively music)